Chuck we're at it again
indeed we are this time I just want to
talk about nothing
oh my god I show up what's the deal with
nothing we're doing a show about nothing
all right that's you want to talk about
nothing let's do this so it's official
we're married now you know that right
somebody hands you a birthday gift right
and it's a box and you open it and and
there's nothing in it you say there's
nothing in it if it's if it's empty you
say there's nothing in it correct yes
and I'd also probably say again really
guys again with the amp with the empty
box thing you know I don't I get into
your social personal family issues okay
how your family members treat you that's
another show
okay all right so so of course there's
air in the box but generally we think of
air and nothing else as nothing right
right there's nothing in the box but of
course there's air in the box right and
I think we think of air is nothing
because you can't see the air at air is
just molecules right we have oxygen
molecule two oxygen atoms together make
the oxygen molecule we have two nitrogen
atoms together make the nitrogen
molecule that's 98% 99% of all the
molecules you are inhaling there's
others a little bit of co2 trace amounts
of other atoms and molecules but the
main ones are oxygen and nitrogen and
they are transparent so you don't think
of it as being something but you can
have another gas and they're like smoke
you open up the box there's smoke in the
box okay because you can see it so often
what we sense or what we declare is or
it is not is based on just how our
senses receive the environment you go up
to a window and so it's it the window is
transparent well if you could if you
could see with microwaves right the
whole room would be transparent because
microwaves pass right through the walls
you know how you know that because you
pull out yourself
which uses microwaves and you get a
signal even if you're in the bathroom
not with my carrier oh you need special
bathroom coverage it's trying to tell
you all right so so huh how many
molecules are there so there's about 10
to the 25th power one with 25 zeros
worth of air molecules in a cubic meter
that's a lot a little bigger than a
cubic yard okay it's a lot of molecules
that's a lot of molecule even have that
that number has a name a septillion sep
tell you septillion that's right so now
you want to do better than that let's
create a laboratory vacuum okay okay
but if air is something more than
nothing then let's get rid of the air
let's go ahead and do that so suck it
out
suck it let's get one of the best
laboratory vacuums there is okay so that
can pump out the molecules and leave you
with about 10 billion molecules per
cubic meter wait a minute
after you suck everything that's that's
what kind of the best you can do with
the best you could do you still got 10
sorry I'm sorry Chuck I took it from 10
to the 25th power to 10 to the 10th are
we using the Dyson Dyson vacuum may
totally kick ass we might do better okay
let's call Dyson co-sponsor this this
big yeah I'm sorry you're not happy with
10 billion molecules per cubic meter
where we started with it's 10 septum
okay sorry about that okay so is that
nothing you might ask okay well let's
forget laboratory vacuums let's leave
Earth to interplanetary space the vacuum
of space okay that's a thousand times
less dense than the best laboratory
vacuum that has about 10 million
molecules per cubic meter we just
dropped by a factor of a thousand
molecules
I'm sorry I didn't know you'd be that
hard to please Chuck I'm trying to get
to nothing we're on our way there oh by
the way there is the very best vacuum
there ever was on earth and it is it is
the it is the track that the hadrons
travel in the Large Hadron Collider in
the CERN particle accelerator in
Switzerland CERN cer in the acronym the
Center for you European nuclear research
okay alright and or research knew Pierre
is France you know so they got to flip
the order so alright so it turns out
that vacuum is the best ever made and
that's a better vacuum than in
interstellar space I'm sorry
interplanetary space so you want the the
most nothing place in the entire solar
system is in the tube where they
accelerate the particles because they
don't want the particles accidentally
hitting some other particles when it's
trying to hit the target that you have
that's gonna probe the origins of the
universe and looking for you know exotic
particles that might even include dark
matter but anyhow let's go from
interplanetary space to interstellar
space okay that's even less now we're
down to a half a million particles per
cubic metre
okay that's pretty wild all right half
only a half of 500,000 five million
correct this is leftover it's a row
meter it's a reminder that the universe
this stuff in the universe all right and
they're places where it has collected
and gathered that's where you get stars
and planets and people where it hasn't
collected and it has a gathered it's
much more scattered much more tenuous
okay so that's interstellar space now
what would you imagine would have less
than interstellar space
intergalactic intergalactic space
because galaxies are gatherings of
matter right so there it would be hard
to find a few atoms of anything for
every 10 cubic meters that's so but it's
still not nothing I'm on my way there
damn you the most impatient this thing
only lasts 10 minutes and you can't even
just we're all the way out into
intergalactic space okay yes I am
light-years away from home and it's like
driving between here and like Vegas
there's just a lot of nothing going on
and I'm still at not at nothing though
you're still not at nothing okay so now
let's so rather than give real live
examples let's give examples that we
would imagine you could produce which is
get rid of those half a million atoms
per ten cubic meters just figure out a
way to have not have them okay so now we
have a completely empty box empty of all
matter okay now we ask is that nothing
yeah because there's nothing about sect
quantum physics there's such a thing as
virtual particles that come into
existence and then go out of existence
in less time than you can actually
measure their existence and totally
empty space is seething with virtual
particles okay so the best nothing you
can ever you can ever make would have no
ordinary matter but would still
nonetheless be seething with virtual
particles okay Wow now let's ask a
question suppose you could step out of
our universe so that there's not even
for X well the no matter and there's not
even the virtual particles I'm willing
to do that
okay so that's there's not even nothing
right
so we could get lazy and just call it
nothing nothing but I I think there's a
greater nothing than even that and this
is what I want to leave you that this is
this is where I want to deposit you the
grater nothing then you ready imagine
you take away all matter and somehow
configure way to where there's not even
virtual particles right you would still
have the laws of physics okay it's a
region of space nothing if the laws of
nature still apply inside that space so
you're thinking of nothing as substance
and I'm thinking of nothing as not even
anything that is anything about anything
so if you systematically remove all laws
of physics all laws of nature then you
have a region of out of can even call it
space because space is a thing space can
bend according to Einstein relativity
that's a thing of space the fabric of
space no matter what's in it will Bend
with or without virtual particles it's
still a thing right okay so if I get rid
of all particles get rid of the very
laws that describe nature then there's
not only not matter there's not energy
there no laws of physics there is no
time itself there you go
no time now Chuck put that in your box
open it and now you have my permission
to say there's nothing about nothing and
what do we call that I'm gonna call it
something what because it's the nothing
that is something which is nothing you
said like a twelve-year-old kid just
something there's nothing there's
something I think it's something there's
nothing so it's just something separate
that that's pretty intense to think
about though because what where you got
me is because no laws of physics now you
can't even have time now you really
there really is no thing they're a
direct correct and you know you could
take this one step higher and say the
fact that I can describe it as being
nothing has given meaning to the thing
allowing me to say that it's not nothing
because I can describe it as having
nothing right so yeah so now that so
philosophically right it's I mean it's
partly a language issue partly a
physical issue what does it mean to be
able to describe something at all that
is nothing that means you've described
something that is a thing right now let
me say let's not even have anything that
you can describe right now you got
nothing what now you got nothing and
what do you call that see you can't call
it anything cause you just contained it
right you've just turned it into a thing
that's a thing that's right oh man see
that's pretty wild there you got it
that is why oh so okay now for those of
you who would like to now go smoke your
marijuana this is what I am saying to
you but for what it's worth there's one
of the layers of multiverses because
there's several layers where their laws
of physics as we know them don't even
apply at all they're not just different
they just don't exist yeah and so that's
another thing we'll talk about the
multiverse in another explainer video
but we got to go check the multiverse
smoking weed
that's not smoke weed yeah all right
this has been yet another
Startalk explainer video Chuck always
good to have you Neil deGrasse Tyson
meeting you
[Applause]
[Music]